Smouse ago press - Pam hi and welcome
back to a new episode of a monisha a
machine for pigs
son of a bee sting there we go
I was like I was think I wasn't speaking
because I was thinking but I was like
there has to be a lever somewhere there
we go there it is
[ __ ] I'm smart I need my genius award
right about now that what did i do
exactly
I thought these gates would open Wow
[ __ ] okay what I what that bathtub is
hiding from me what are you doing Matt
oh oh why is what someone spy awesome I
need one it I mean I mean no this is
horrible
who did this is a psychopath or a genie
what what is that okay it's gonna be
okay we're all friends here we're all
friends I don't have any friends in this
game though
what is that machine I'm not sure I want
to know what that machine is you [ __ ]
rats gangbang whatever okay whoa what is
this
can I take something there I want to put
something or maybe I should go
interesting okay huh wait wait us
why can't I go out okay
now whatever was in there it's not in
there anymore oh I do not appreciate
this oh no no this is convenient this
store wasn't hi hi hi hands are bleeding
raw I scrub and scrub but the smell will
not lift how can I hold my children with
these hands now how can I kiss them
goodnight with lips that have issued
such instruction okay and it seems this
kind of thing is reassembling I'm not
sure I don't like it sorry Jay I
definitely don't like you but I like you
you're cool okay yes we shall
don't parents ah don't cry for me just
go on but nice that I did not mean to do
that I mean there we go much better okay
so now oh great
that is just fantastic I know where to
go now bras baby oh mama
here we are it's gonna go straight now
there we go well I will cry all the way
home okay what is it
I will have nothing now you have me in
piggy okay so I'm happy I'm very happy
that there was no blood while walking
here so I think that means I think that
means we're pretty good I think I hate
Oh wine for me thanks
okay now there is this machine now I
don't know what's up with it but I don't
know spinning things it's fun oh we're
back here well then what they oh this is
open out excellent okay well we shall go
over here
[Music]
okay I'm just getting I'm beyond sick of
you now at this point [ __ ] potatoes
what is this oh I know they're hidden
door
really they should just rename this
amnesia hidden doors every [ __ ] where
courtyards quarter-ton oh okay we're
here awesome
Barney nope
just let me in place no come on
blanks that's in the margins god damn it
well I guess all right baby here nice
Sun a place man it's been an action Andy
I need help
oh look who's here
just chilling aren't you no no what did
you do I like this kind of steampunk ish
design maybe I'm wrong by calling it
that but it looks like it
I don't want to go oh we're but nice
knowing you bros s been a good run
hasn't it this is it we're trapped in
here unless no weird [ __ ] great hey
buddy I said I don't give a [ __ ] freely
[Music]
how did they possibly know I mean we
were undone you're too late
what are you need me to do how can I
find yes matters through the piston
proven into the tunnels then find the
water I will help you where I can but
you must be swift what do you mean
little friend okay well I kind of got
that we're looking for today
whoa what is this it's this a puzzle
this is like a battery area I know what
it's called in English oh yeah this is
one of those I know what they're calling
English but what I love things I better
bring you with me
why me why me okay all right just some
some crawling in the in the water
there's no water what am I talking I'm
done I'm done
you start up that was not a coincidence
was it you piece of [ __ ] you're coming
with me batty booty no no no shut up
what's doing that please stop not a big
fan of beating oh there we go good thing
I brought this thing because that looks
pretty busted hey machine still crying
pretty sure about that one
another one right there son of a they're
everywhere Fields God all right Yolo
not chatter what the hell I'd I could
easily pull that up about whatever all
right gotta dig deeper huh what is this
it seems to be controlled to dos - what
is that - exactly
Oh okay let's pull it down
I get the feeling I will have to run no
you think I can go up maybe I can
I don't know
[Music]
know what is happening what is happening
what is happening what is happening what
is happening
stop bones okay I have carried this
world on my back with its legs about me
you giant piece of [ __ ] wretches so I
am given birth to nothing but machinery
that's pretty hard that's pretty high
let's be honest BAM
and that's how we're done let's check
out whoa [ __ ] giant battles why is it
missing
what's that can't noise supposed to be I
actually don't want to know I would have
thought I was crying now
[Music]
well it seems like we got the machinery
running so what else is there to do
maybe I opened this oh my [ __ ] god
what do you want from me
I swear to God I swear it I swear the
pills myself what a hell does that even
mean
what is this where does this go oh this
is last one isn't it
I need another
what is in here
please let there be a fusion here I just
need one oh cool
sweet sweet child just gonna take you
we're gonna take you and we're gonna get
the [ __ ] away from here okay don't say
everything is fine everything is so what
Oh
stop okay you know what don't get up
don't finish
yes yes adios [ __ ]
[Music]
oh I will yes yes I'm well just come to
pay cheap opportunity oh it's gonna be
good
what is this what's that are we going
deeper
[Music]
your eyes it will be fine you just lie
down what happened why not then simply
die in that jungle amongst those dead
temples I think this is it bro we're
gonna start the machine well
[Music]
okay
the owner everyone's right
to do this
one
to
I don't want okay straight eyebrows hope
you enjoy that episode it's getting
interesting and we're only just getting
started so leave a like if you enjoyed
watching it subscribe to be on the
bridge
[Music]